fans have loved science fiction cinema
for about as long as we've had movies
but as popular as the genre has always
been not every flight of fantasy becomes
the next metropolis Star Wars or arrival
many productions are guilty of
committing a variety of unforgivable
sci-fi sins from unbelievable worlds to
unlikable characters or bungling
important story details these all came
up short and landed a spot in cinematic
history as the worst sci-fi movies ever
made
passengers 2016's
space bound Odyssey passengers looked
good on paper but it was ruined by its
script director morten tyldum had just
been nominated for a Best Director Oscar
for the intimidation game and Chris
Pratt and Jennifer Lawrence were more
than capable as co-stars the ads made it
look like a beautiful sci-fi romance but
then people saw the movie Pratt's
hibernating character is woken up by a
ship malfunction and spends a year in
total isolation then he wakes up
Lawrence's character even though he
knows she won't be able to re-enter
hibernation and will therefore be robbed
of her life on the colony planet
although she's angry when this truth is
revealed a dramatic finale where the
pair saves the ship leads her to accept
spending her life with him critic
Rebecca Hawks called passengers a creepy
ode to manipulation many others agreed
that Pratt's creepiness and the fact
that it's forgiven ruined the movie
which sits at 31 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes Howard the Duck produced by
George Lucas 1986 as Howard the Duck has
all sorts of problems it's based on a
Marvel comic book about a sarcastic
talking duck from another dimension but
where the comic is satirical the movie
has no point of view it does however
portray an intimate relationship between
a woman and duck which a lot of viewers
found pretty gross legendary film critic
Gene Siskel spoke for audiences
everywhere when he asked who was this
stupid film made for the answer is
nobody if we're going by the number of
people who went to see it know they know
I'm a yo-yo years before their stable of
Comics characters conquered the box
office Howard the Duck proved Marvel
wasn't anywhere close to being ready for
Hollywood alien from LA the most notable
thing about 1988 alien from LA is that
it stars iconic 80s model Kathy Ireland
who
an awkward nerd who only becomes hot as
she journeys through the strange
underground civilization of Atlantis in
search of her father directed by noted
schlock Meister Albert poon the movie is
dull and visually unappealing despite
Ireland's presence while spending an old
legend as a time-honored sci-fi
tradition putting Atlantis under the
dirt instead of under the sea feels like
the budget-friendly choice the whole
thing is memorable only for the episode
of Mystery Science Theater 3000 that
makes fun of it
laser blast having also landed a Mystery
Science Theater episode laser blast
tells the story of a bullied teenage boy
who finds a laser cannon and a matching
badge out in the desert when he wears
the badge he can fire the cannon but the
badge starts growing into his body and
the power slowly turns him into a
murderous monster he also happens to be
the target of some Dino like alien cops
who ultimately put an end to his rampage
the stop-motion aliens are easily the
best part of the movie with director
Charles band claiming the design of ET
was directly based on them and speaking
of everyone's favorite extraterrestrial
Mack and meat producer RJ Lewis believed
it was time for quote a new generation
to have it CT which was odd since Mac
and me came out in 1988 just six years
after et's release Lewis had a working
relationship with McDonald's from his
time in advertising and had a grand plan
to get them involved in cross marketing
the movie but the idea didn't land with
audiences critic Chris Hicks commented
I'm not sure I've ever seen a movie that
is as crass a 90-minute commercial as
Mac and me on top of that the plot was a
ripoff of ET but with worst special
effects and an alien who wasn't nearly
as cute galaxy no an attempt to make a
fun sexy movie in the mold of Barbarella
1980s galaxy 'no didn't have the talent
of Barbarella star jane fonda or
director rojava dean instead it had
Playboy Playmate Dorothy stratten and
director William Sachs who had
previously made the incredible melting
man which was also pretty bad
Stratton looked great but was actually
playing a sexless Android who doesn't
even talk until she reprograms herself
halfway through the movie
McLean's she cooks she does windows and
more sachs attempts to parody sci-fi
hits like Star Wars and alien put his
critic Jeffrey Anderson put it the jokes
are little more than references and they
simply don't work Stratton was
tragically murdered by her estranged
husband two months after the movie was
released which cast a pall over the film
these days rather than being discussed
on its own merits it appears as an
addendum to Stratton's tragic real-life
story
[Music]